uh i want to start with congratulations
on the movie um
i had a blast with this it's i'm going
to use the term kind of violent and i
love that a little bit you know um uh so
i have an individual question for you um
to start things off haley who works for
collider big fan and she had a question
and i'm gonna read it so i don't screw
this thing up uh you've defeated or
killed michael myers a few times in this
franchise how have you had to reevaluate
how to play that moment and evolve the
character approach to make them unique
and how was the approach to the he's
still not dead moment in this sequel
different
wow that's a that's a mouthful of a
question that's not it's going to be a
mouthful of an answer here's what i will
say the beautiful
dawning realization that michael is not
dead for every character
judy
andy
jamie
omar
all of the
people
hawkins
um are
horror film
acting moments we all have them
um
[Music]
mine is is
is panic
and rage because
i believe that lori strode would have
been happily dead in the back of that
truck she saved her daughter she saved
her granddaughter she killed michael
myers i think of lori bled out
in the arms of her family she would
think that is a hero's death
so when she finds out that she not only
survived and had to do the surgery that
he is alive that tommy comes in
and tells her
it's um uh it's an acting moment that
i've played a few times and i guess i'm
good at it
i mean i'm honestly there's a just a
moment of truth and i can't act the
truth it's just you have to hear
something
that is shocking
in a way that you don't see coming and i
think that's been a big part of this
franchise uh for all three of you i love
love learning like cool that's gonna
curse a cool [ __ ] behind the scenes
about the making of movies and uh i'm
just curious for each for all three of
you what do you think might surprise
fans to learn about the making of this
film in particular
i'll go first
most movies
which the three of us can attest to
although this may not be actually i'm
going to say it because i don't i can't
speak for you and i certainly can't
speak for you in fact you probably have
not experienced most movies
when people do this together and they
talk about them with people from the
movie together they all pretend that
everything was great between them but
then as soon as they're done they go i
often have gone to my trailer and put my
head in a pillow and this
is a real one of the first of 150 movies
that i've ever done in terms of behind
the scenes it's one of the first movies
not the only but one of the few movies
where i can really say
i have a great time with these two
people i have great respect for them
we've had a great time
working and not working and we just get
along very well we send each other
emails and it's all like a very happy
family which is always what you pretend
but in my case anyway it's very rarely
the reality
yeah i would just add it was a very
difficult
shoot in terms of the
technical elements that we're trying to
achieve in a short
and economical time period
uh
it was massive ambition
hundreds of extras
uh logistics of practical
ambition of practical
makeup effects and and
kill gags
and we're shooting seven weeks of nights
which for a guy that goes to bed at 9 30
is very difficult and so after a period
of weeks it was it was it was wonderful
blissful madness because of as jason
mentioned the collaborative spirit that
we have and the enjoyment we have of
each other not just the three of us here
but everyone from the script supervisor
the ad department the camera department
art department sound department wardrobe
everybody kind of had that unique loving
spirit about the franchise that we get
to play in what a sandbox incredible and
yet it was so stressful that i had no
idea what we were making
uh at a point of chaos and mayhem and
it's just a a creative bloodbath at a
point and
and as as jason says about put his face
into a pillow there was a point before i
watched the first cut of the movie
thinking
what could this possibly be like we have
three cameras hosing down mayhem for
seven weeks at night and i'm out of my
mind uh and it's the first uh i think
this is like the 12th or 13th film i've
made
and it was our 14th
yeah 14. and then and then it was the
first rough cut where i thought oh this
is a real this is a real fun one
this is some naughty boy trick-or-treat
fun so uh
from the first cut i saw and that was
the first time that it ever happened so
i almost feel like it was the production
was an out-of-body experience to go into
a uh a joyous editing process
i have to stop there thank you so much
what two minutes for jamie no no no i
don't give a [ __ ] about answering the
question because i'm not the filmmaker
i'm the actor no all i was going to say
to you is that we also have never lied
to each other
and there have been a lot of times a lot
of tense moments where we could have
lied when we never did and we never did
and i think the fact that we all know
that we've not lied to each other we've
told the truth at moments when maybe we
don't want to hear the truth
that i think that has also given us all
the confidence
to know that you can trust us each other
each other and in this kind of a world
to be able to know that i'm going to
look at you and tell you the truth and
you will and you will
i i think that's
uh doesn't come often it doesn't yeah i
was going to say that's the exception
to the rule exception not the rule uh
and that's
so i wanted to apologize for
interrupting you you didn't interrupt me
oh stop it not at all i'm just letting
you know that that i know they're
because they do this all the time yeah
no i was getting i understand but i just
i think if if if i really had to analyze
this it's because from the moment it
began we've all told the truth to each
other which has yielded then the safety
net
petri dish
sandbox that's safe and not scary i mean
it's really scary that's not true it's
incredibly scary it's just it's safe for
us as creatives on that note
congratulations thank you very much
you